[Music]
all right let's run out to New Jersey
and talk to Maggie what up Maggie how we
doing hey just partying what are you
doing we are partying until the wheels
are falling
off not true at all we're being kind of
boring actually Maggie what's
up uh I have a question what's
up my H fiance lied to me for five years
about a day trading count he hat uh oh
he yeah he claims he made uh 200,000 and
lost it all and during that time I paid
all the bills and I wound up doubling
the mortgage on my house and I'm having
a real hard time moving past this even
though I found out in
February H you doubled your mortgage or
you've been doubling up on your
mortgage I had to uh I had to refinance
it twice Oh
shoot what has he been
doing well now he's been trying to
rectify the situation by working his
tail off and trying to get his account
back but and other than this he was the
perfect guy he was the perfect partner
no he wasn't and I'm old no he wasn't
and I'm older and I just I'm like I do
not want to have to start again you're
right he
wasn't and if he's lying to you about
this he's lying to you about other
things and you know
that I I really don't though he SW I I
think I he swears no has he given you a
print out of the last five years years
of this trading
account yes I've seen all the I've seen
all the information there's been total
transparency moving
forward and so why are you choosing to
let what happened you you chose to
stay and so you've been choosing since
February to not move past this how
come I think I've got a couple scking
points that are that are getting to me
what are
they one is I think I I can't get past
grieving the life I was was promised
okay uh another one is how elaborate the
lies I was told are because he was you
know he was said he was going to take
the money out but then he couldn't
access the money so that just got crazy
um and I just I have a hard time
thinking that you know somebody who
really loves me would not do this to me
yeah and I'm having a hard time trust in
myself I I I think this that's what was
the hardest part like yeah I just told
that last caller did you hear that I
just told the last caller when somebody
cheats on you which is what he did he
cheated on you yes
um there's the cheating there's the
imagining your spouse with somebody else
right that actual physical act of him
sleeping with somebody else there's the
thought
of the actual picture of you going to
work or you going to the bank to pull
out a second mortgage and him watching
you go knowing he's got this other
account there's that image right which
is devastating M and underneath that is
what I think is a scarier Prospect which
is Maggie no longer trusts
Maggie yep and that's
unnerving especially at my age and I've
been through a lot all my previous
relationships were abusive of course and
I I really worked really hard to you
know go to therapy get myself right get
right in my head you know deal with
everything and now it's just all that's
been kind of shattered again yeah
why are you still with this guy yes
why
Ah that's a good
question part of it's Financial we live
together and we have to um part of it
100% don't agree with
that it's not true that's a story you're
telling yourself for the life that you
want you're willing to to share a bed
with somebody that you don't love or
maybe you love the idea of them but
someone who hurt you deeply and you're
still unable to now I love him I love
him completely I know I do okay so
someone you love but also somebody who
hurts you and you can't fully exhale in
your own
home what else why else do you think you
can't you're still with
them
um I think that I don't want to start
over again at my age
you keep mentioning your age how old are
you I'm 54 I'll be 55 next year so what
are you willing to put up with if you
had slept with your friend would that be
enough that would not be tolerated I
know this is this is the same thing I
get it it's it's Financial um infidelity
it's it's the same thing I totally get
that have you ever y'all sat down and
pulled his credit report
yep and there's no other accounts on
there
nope this was just a onetime isolated
thing where he was running how much did
he did he get and
lose
200k how does somebody filter $200,000
in and out of their
relationship does he make that kind of
money or did you turn your a blind eye I
turned a blind eye like I did in my
other relationships and that's another
problem I'm having with myself right now
yeah so are you mad at him or you mad at
Maggie that you went through all this
counseling you've been through hell and
back and then here you go
again both
okay here's the hard truth I'm going to
give you because I love
you you've chosen to
stay mhm you've chosen to allow him to
stay in your home m mhm and every day
you're choosing
misery and I would suggest you need to
make one or two different
choices either I don't feel miserable
every day though but I'm listening go
ahead I'm
sorry you you have learned the skill
over 50 years of your
life to
smile to brush things under the rug and
to take how Maggie feels about something
and shove it so far down that you can
get through a day true or
false 100%
yeah the only problem is as the great
Bessel vender culk says the body keeps
the score you can't outrun your nervous
system so while you're like everything's
great and wonderful and I know where all
the money is and it's all good and he's
still handsome and I'm not alone and I'm
so so desperate to not be
alone I'll settle for this cuz it's all
okay your nervous system says that guy's
not
safe or maybe it's saying Maggie you're
not safe again you're not safe again
you're not trustworthy
again
Fair it's it's all directed at me you're
right what happened to Maggie that you
think so little of
Maggie lots of abuse yeah narcissistic
abuse for about pretty much my whole
life I'm sorry parental than than an
ex-husband yeah
yeah and I think you know I thought I'd
move past everything I mean I'd been in
therapy for years and years and years
you know I left my ex-husband I got
right in my head I you know I did all
the therapy I had to do there and now
then this happen yeah thing about
therapy thought was a perfect
relationship yeah turns out to be just
the same as the other one just different
right better but yeah some similarities
for
sure so how can I
help I need to know what to do what to
do for
what I probably already know what to do
don't I well I mean it's it's if you
were my sister I would tell
you strongly consider taking a break
because your B you haven't slept
yet if you were my sister I would put my
hand on both sides of your face and I
look you as deep into your eyes as I
could and I would tell you I love you
and you're worth more than
this you're worth a more than yet
another abusive relationship except the
abuse use here is with somebody who's
kind instead of somebody who
yells he's kind and sweet and
loving and he watched his fiance or his
wife continue to shovel the hole to Hell
deeper and deeper and deeper while he
was over here
playing playing leono DiCaprio at the at
the roulette
table except he called it Wall
Street that is nothing I have not
said and you're worth more than
that I know am there's one of two things
happening here either in your guts deep
in your guts you know there's other
things out
there you know the truth is not fully on
the table that's one or
two you have not fully come back to the
table which I'll say in a in a kind of a
Twist is cruel to
him because if you say you're going to
stay he messed up and he messed up bad
and then he lied to you and lied to you
and lied to you and together y all dug
quite a hole for
yourselves you are the one who went and
got a second mortgage and a third
mortgage that was a choice you made M
absolutely so here's the
hole but if you said I'm all in I for
give you you've come clean here's all
the information on the
table but you're still one foot out
that's cruel it's not
cool you're absolutely right and and I
do know that and I I've believe me I've
been back and forth and back and forth
and I that that makes me feel as bad as
anything else well I mean feeling bad is
not going to solve it you know what I
mean it's a matter it's a it's a matter
of saying
okay I'm going to try for 30 days to be
all in what does that mean that means
I'm going to carry a journal with me at
at all times okay and every time I have
get a sense in my gut that he's not
telling the truth I'm going to write it
down okay every time I get a sense in my
gut that something's not right doesn't
feel right I'm going to write it down
I'm going to stop where I'm at kind of
like when I first started counting
calories when I had to get control of my
eating every meal I stepped into the
bathroom and pulled my phone out to put
it into this little app I have it was so
annoying and it was every single
time and that's how over time I learned
to trust my body to trust what in on the
plate in front of me to trust all the
things see what I'm saying yeah I need
to see the patterns you got to start is
my body crazy is there something else
here or is this part of the healing
journey and every time you have a uh you
feel something bubbling up say the words
out loud I'm feeling vulnerable here
honey
and I'm feeling a distance between us
I'm feeling a sense of panic I'm feeling
a sense of anxiety I'm feeling a sense
of I have one of the old thoughts
zooming back in my head and it's just
sending me off into a tail spin for a
second I'm going to go for a walk I'll
be right
back and what you're doing is you're
practicing taking control of your body
back
see what I'm saying absolutely the work
Mak perfect sense it's just hard it's
going to be
hard nothing's fun about it but are you
convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
that he's been completely open with you
100%
Allin since it happened uhhuh yes I am I
am yes do you think things happened
before and uh he just didn't tell you
everything
um I think it was a lot of panic and him
lying to himself and him setting
unrealistic goals for himself because of
the goals he had for our relationship
okay I think if I didn't feel that way I
wouldn't be able to forgive him if I
don't know if that makes sense but that
he got he was trying to he's trying to
do something beautiful and then he
freaked out and it went sideways and
then he freaked out and freaked out and
freaked out and then he dug himself a
huge
mess yeah that's what I think happened
okay that's very um very istic of you I
know and I know that's very generous but
after hours of conversation I have come
to that conclusion okay then I think
your your decision moving forward is am
i g to forgive Maggie for having missed
it
again
yep right and maybe every time it
bubbles up your conversation is not with
him but it's with Maggie Maggie we
missed it and we're we're we're back
now right because I look at the budget
every week
I look at our accounts every week he
brings home at them every day yeah he
brings home his he brings home his past
tuub every week and I see
it right you see what I'm saying no
absolutely and so I think it's just a
matter of slow learning how to trust
Maggie and I I don't know a way to do
this without writing it down getting it
out of your body onto a piece of
paper I don't know I was talking to my
friend Dr Steven boner today um who's a
coach and he I mean we're just talking
about that exact thing I don't know a
path forward unless you get it out of
your body onto paper and so carry a
journal with
you and maybe ask yourself is this about
him or is this about
Maggie how could I do this again I'm
learning I'm learning how in the world
could I get with another abusive guy
that doesn't tell me the truth that dug
a hole like this how in the world could
I go take out a second and third
mortgage on my house instead of just
selling it and moving M to an apartment
how in the world did I let that happen I
did I'm going own reality I'm going to
choose reality I'm going to move
forward